well now to our exclusive with Real
Housewife of New Jersey Teresa Giudice
interview since a judge ruled that her
husband Joe would be deported to Italy
after serving his three-year prison
sentence for bankruptcy fraud our Brooke
Anderson talked to Teresa about that
traumatizing moment what was the first
thing that went through your mind when
the judge issued that order of
deportation like I was I was devastated
we live in this country of freedom and
everything you're supposed to keep
families together not break them apart
did you ever think that could be a
possibility I mean very slim chance just
because you know it is a white-collar
crime Joe called to you after the
hearing did he cry no you know it takes
both of us a lot to cry when we spoke
with him last he did seem strong and and
tough you know I think going to jail is
easy part I just want to get out you
know as quickly as I can
but do you think that is an act is he
just trying to be that way no I said I
doesn't break down I'm sure he guys but
you know I mean I know this whole thing
is killing him inside and you know he
feels you know just guilty about
everything do you think the judge was
too harsh the judge went by the law and
you know so now we have the right to
appeal and that's where we're gonna go
Teresa tells me the hardest part of the
situation is watching the toll it has
taken on their four daughters aged 9 to
17 how did you tell them what's going on
my brother called gia because he heard
it on the news so that's how my oldest
found out and I was really upset I took
ivory Lynn Milania together
Gabriella teared up Milania hysterical
like she was like a mess your youngest
is only nine years old does she even
comprehend what's happening um she's the
only one that I didn't tell Joe has been
gone since she's six and it's sad like
she needs her daddy home how his prison
changed him he's definitely changed for
the better for the better
how's he doing he looks amazing I think
he looks the best he ever looked is he
working out a lot is he what's he doing
in there when I met him he weighed 160
and now he's 170 so he's pumping a
little iron he's hard as a rock
[Music]